so this is a little bit of a jokey
question but go with me uh is it true or
false uh is it true that you and Denzel
Were Watching White Lotus together and
said okay well we're going to be making
another equalizer we need to follow that
format and go to Italy
that's false but I was watching White
Lotus that's true I did watch what I
love this with my family yeah but nah
I'd never watched it with Denzel okay
being serious uh I remember on the first
movie I did a set visit and you guys
talked about it remember Denzel talking
about this character is something that I
really want to play for a while this is
something I I think could be my
franchise what do you and and it's
people say that all the time but it
never actually comes to fruition you
know like the movie does okay never no
sequels what do you think it is about
this character that has you know uh
resonated with so many people that's
allowed you guys to make three films now
yeah I think they're connected to him
because he's a common man like he's not
you know there's nothing fancy about him
or anything you know he's uh
it seems like somebody you could know
you know you sit down and have a tea
with or you know a friend of yours uh he
just happens to be a brutal Destroyer
when when it comes time to do that but
um I think that's what people are
connecting to you know
you can see yourself in Robert McCall
talk a little bit about you you got you
have designed and worked on a number of
Set uh pieces in these in the trilogy
which set peace in the three films was
like the biggest pain in the ass or the
one you were like
you know what I mean uh in the second
one
the storm and all that
just a pain in the ass you know just the
wind and the dead and it's just you you
have no control of anything it's just a
pain in the ass you know it's just like
who wrote this no kidding you know yeah
that was a tough one that was a tough
one so there is some pretty brutal
violence in the third one which of
course I'm a fan of I'm all in yeah but
like talk a little bit about like it's
pretty violent how did you guys come to
that decision that this is going to be
you know what I mean yeah you're getting
some pretty brutal stuff what's his
final Masterpiece you know to take out
some bad guys that deserved it you know
and and it's set up in the movie when
you first meet Vincent the the brother
the the head of the the Kimora there
that their
um the worst are the worst you know the
way they treat people kick them out of
their homes and these sort of things so
they had to go in in a the worst way
they had to know what it felt like to be
terrorized sure uh I you know that I'm
obsessed with talking about the editing
process because that's where it all
comes together so talk a little about
what you learned when you some any
surprises that hit you when you got in
the editing room or maybe from friends
and family screenings that impacted the
finished film uh yeah you know I think
the thing that I always
get out of it uh
the editing process is it's a rhythm for
me it's a pacing you know that that I've
focused a lot on but also um you talk
about the violence the brutality of it
somehow while I'm filming it is not
enough and then I see it in the editing
Bay or show friends and family and they
say
you didn't hold back and I'm like okay I
guess it's enough but that's always
interesting for me you know I I I wanted
more
but that's because I'm too close I was
too close to it
but you know I find friends and family
and in the editing process that we we
have enough it's it's more than enough
yeah it's interesting because with with
some violence some there's a line for me
the like I'm obviously an effed up
individual but like some people just
seeing a little bit of blood they're
like that's too much right and other
people you know it's like it's like the
thing in someone's head right right yeah
that's the balance is where is that
balance right where's it especially when
you're dealing with a you know a certain
audience uh they kind of the younger
audience sometimes want a little more or
they want to you know and then there's a
little more mature audience that Denzel
fans as well older women older men over
35 or certain ages that you know you get
to even like my age where I got children
now where you go okay that's I'm good
that's enough I'm satisfied right you
kind of you know it just kind of happens
so finding the balance is always the key
I'm a huge fan of uh Robert Richardson
and you've worked with him before talk a
little bit about the way you and Robert
collaborate on set in terms of you know
the shots and just the look of the film
we we're great collaborators he's my
brother man I have a great time with
Robert um we spend a lot of time in the
locations taking photos walking around
we go to the museums you know just the
environment what is the environment what
is it called for uh the look of it uh
feeling the way the place
fills you know Italy's old up in the
hills the houses are built them in the
Hills the Mediterraneans there's there's
you know texture on the walls how do you
capture that how do you not make it feel
like a travel log film or anything like
that you know uh and still keep it
gritty and and organic those sort of
conversations we have a lot and then we
go around and we we take a lot of photos
we spend a lot of time together doing
that I'm almost out of time with you so
I have to ask you about something else
that I'm really looking forward to which
is you're doing a Michael Jackson
project yes I I definitely have to ask
you what's the status of that project is
that your next thing it looks like it's
going to be my next thing we just had to
pause it because of the strike so I'm
just kind of waiting to see where it all
falls out but yes that's my next project
if you don't mind me asking one of the
things about like biopics is sometimes
it depicts the whole life sometimes it
depicts a certain period in that
person's life are you what kind of movie
is this going to be I'm going to show
you the facts as I know it
give you a better Insight on Michael
um
uh as an artist as a human being uh good
bad the ugly and let people decide for
themselves on what they feel about
Michael Jackson but
that's what I want to do I think he's
it's worthwhile oh I I I yeah I have a
million other things but I got to ask
you one other thing so terminal list was
a huge hit for Prime video massive right
obviously they're continuing are you
involved in any more of the terminal
list oh yeah yeah we were heavily
involved uh for the prequel until the
strike absolutely yeah I'm deeply
involved yeah I was gonna say are you
gonna direct any episodes uh if I'm
available I definitely will yeah I
absolutely will I enjoyed it uh yeah I
enjoy it say it again I enjoy the
terminal list I love it well I mean
what's interesting about that is Chris
Pratt on Amazon on Prime video is just a
beast oh yeah I love it man that's what
I want to do is I'll direct probably one
or two to Chris's in you know because
it's the prequel with Taylor as well so
yeah